معنا الان من تلبيب مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس نرصد معك اخر الاعلانات
وبيانات جيش الاحتلال بخصوص المعارك وما
يجري في غزه
حاليا بالفعل ازدهار لعل البارز هو اعلان
الكتيبه 717 وهي تابعه لقوات المدرعات
الاسرائيليه في من كتائب الهندسه انسحابها
وانهاء عملياتها العسكر ر في شمال قطاع
غزه وهي احدى الوحدات من سلاح المدرعات
التي اشتركت في العمليات العسكريه وهي
تتبع للواء الناحل البري في الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا ياتي في اطار حديث اعلامي
متزايد في الايام الاخيره نقلا عن مصادر
عسكريه اسرائيليه غير مؤكده حقيقه رسميا
من الجانب من جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي على
وجه الخصوص لكن وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
تتحدث عن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا او
سيبدا في غضون الايام القليله المقبله
التقلي من وجوده العسكري على الاقل في
المناطق الشماليه لا يعرف بعد فيما اذا
كانت الخطه ترمي الى اعاده انتشار القوات
الاسرائيليه في تلك المناطق او تموضع جديد
او حتى انسحاب الى غلاف غزه لكن من الواضح
بان قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي في المنطقه
الشماليه للقطاع اصبحت اقل بكثير مما كانت
عليه في الايام الاولى للهجوم ووم البري
لا سما بعد ان كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد
سحب الفرقه 36 كما تعلمين في الاسابيع
الماضيه وسحب اعدادا كبيره ايضا من الجنود
في صفوف الاحتياط منذ مطلع العام الجديد
واعلان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ايضا قبل
نحو اسبوعين على ان العمليات العسكريه
الكبرى في المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع غزه قد
انتهت لكن هذا لا يعني بانه لا
يوجد وجود عسكري اسرائيل في المناطق
الشماليه الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا يعيد
انتشاره كما يبدو في
تلك المناطق وبدا يقوم بالمرحله الثالثه
من العمليات العسكريه بحسب التوصيف
العسكري وهي العمليات المبنيه على عمليات
هجوميه محدده المكان ومحدده الزمان وبناء
على معلومات استخباراتيه فيما يقوم لواء
اخر ازدهار بتقطيع اوصال قطاع غزه ما بين
مناطق شماليه ومناطق جنوبيه هذا اللواء
ينشط في المنطقه الواقعه جنوب مدينه غزه
ويقطع اوصال القطاع الى قسمين ويمنع
الفلسطينيين الذين هجروا قصرا في خضم
الحرب البريه او الهجوم البري من العوده
الى ما تبقى من منازلهم في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه دا عن ذلك الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يواصل عمليات الهدم
الممنهجه
لالاف المباني والش شقق السكنيه تحديدا
تلك القريبه من السياج الامني مع غلاف غزه
في عمق يزيد على كيلومتر او كيلت ونصف في
بعض الاماكن وذا بغرض اقامه
اي بعد امني او عمق امني جديد في تلك
المناطق من خلال اقامه منطقه عازله توفر
نقطه او عمقا امنيا لبلدات غلاف غزه
الاسرائيليه من اجل تمكين الاسرائيليين من
العوده الى هذه البلدات صحيفه جلوبس
الاسرائيليه الاقتصاديه كانت اشارت الى ان
عدد المنازل الذي التي او المباني التي تم
هدمها في اطار هذا ال هذه الخطه فاق ربما
1700 مبنى ولكن اذا ما ضربنا هذا الرقم
باربعه طوابق او خمسه طوابق واحيانا ثلاثه
ربما نصل الى عشرات او الاف ال الشقق
السكنيه وهذا عدد كبير من المنازل المحطمه
المدمره نم كليا التي لم تعد اهله للعيش
والسكن والجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم بتدميرها
بشكل ممنهج في اطار عدم تمكين الفلسطينيين
من العوده اليها وانشاء هذه المنطقه
العازله التي سيسيطر عليها امنيا بحسب
مخططاته العسكريه فقط نشير ازدهار الى ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يواصل عملياته
بزخم كبير في المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه
تحديدا في مدينه خانيونس شكرا جزيلا لك من
تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام ال